[Music]
this morning on our saturday sessions a
return appearance from phoebe
bridgers she was just 22 when she made
stranger in the alps her acclaimed
2017 debut since then she's been
involved in collaborations with connor
oberst and others
and became a producer of albums herself
including her latest release
we'll hear some of that new music coming
up but first anthony mason spoke with
bridgers about something familiar
to all of us coping with this pandemic
earlier this month phoebe bridgers
performed live
at the red rocks unpaused festival near
denver
in front of a stunning natural backdrop
and an amphitheater
of empty seats how was that it was
wild it was amazing though it felt
everybody had so much more appreciation
for playing a show
it was the first time she'd played her
new album
punisher live with her band but her tour
began and ended with that performance
it must be kind of weird releasing an
album at a time like this when you can't
tour i mean in some ways does it feel
like the music almost isn't out there if
you're not
performing it yeah the minute i turn my
phone off i don't exist
you know that's what it feels like it
feels like i didn't make anything i
already kind of have like a
imposter syndrome issue so when i finish
a song that i like
every single time i'm like oh that's the
that's the last time that'll ever happen
i mean as a performer you're so used to
the feedback on stage and you're not
getting it
i know it's like true ego death you know
i like i've never i've never had such a
hard time
affirming myself the 26 year old singer
songwriter says
she pushed herself to sign up a new
therapist
during the pandemic why did you force
yourself to do it
just because i could feel the weight of
of isolation
like starting to break me and i was like
you know what there are people whose
entire job it is to
help and it's time i've been ignoring it
for
way too long people are finding
themselves missing things that they
didn't
they didn't value before i cannot wait
to hate touring again
i cannot wait to complain again about
airports
but what i would give to have two random
hours to kill
like trying to find snacks and magazines
at a hudson news
like that sounds great to me right now
her second solo album has been getting a
lot of love from
fans but bridger says she's often her
own
worst critic you're hard on yourself as
a songwriter
yeah i hate everything until i love it
and then i think i'm god
it's a very weird uh you know
binary it's like it's like i either am
like you are trash and you're only good
because you surround yourself with
talented people
and every single good song you've ever
written was a was
a fluke accident and then i am god
nobody is as good as me you know
everything my mom says about me is true
that's quite a pendulum totally it's
when you're like standing on stage and
people are screaming your lyrics it's
really easy to get kind of a big head
and then you close your door to your
hotel room and you're like do i have any
friends
so so yeah squaring all that up with my
therapist